bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 16 juin à
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale entouré de nous inviter
mais également des journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite on commence avec
les titres de cette édition le quartier
de gars bécane de la verrière est au
coeur d'une polémique le projet de
réaménagement a divisé la commune et
l'agglomération détail dans cette
édition et retour sur l'attentât aux
états unis à orlando où un terroriste
assassiné 49 personnes dans un club gay
qu'en est il du climat homophobe
la situation se dégrade elle en france
pour nous en parler ce soir notre invité
jérôme andré président de la chef
prévention vous entendrez également le
conseiller régional du parti radical de
gauche eddie ait et impro scop enfin
c'est du théâtre d'impro mais sur les
réseaux sociaux avec l'application
périscope une idée originale de hand
hippie mort et wan et antoine rabot
comédien est membre de déclic théâtre
un concept qui rencontre un certain
succès auprès des spectateurs et que
nous vous ferons découvrir et pour
ouvrir ce journal cette information le
président de la république françois
hollande sera demain à versailles rendra
personnellement hommage au couple de
policiers sauvagement assassiné ce lundi
à magnanville dans l'essonne il
présidera donc vendredi matin à la
préfecture de versailles
une cérémonie officielle pour honorer le
policier et sa compagne elle se
déroulera également en présence de leurs
familles ainsi que du premier ministre
manuel valls et du ministre de
l'intérieur
bernard à cazeneuve et un grand élan de
solidarité est née de la part de la
population après ce drame suite à
l'afflux des dons à financer financier
par le public pour la famille de jean
baptiste salvin et sa compagne jessica
génère le ministre de l'intérieur vient
de transmettre sur les réseaux sociaux
les coordonnées bancaires et l'ordre
pour les dons qui reviendrait donc à
leurs familles la gestion de ces dons
sera donc encadrée par une fondation du
ministère de l'intérieur la fondation
jean moulin si vous souhaitez apporter
vous aussi votre soutien toutes les
informations s'affichent à l'écran vous
les avez vus et prenons à présent la
direction de la verrière c
dostie en attente le projet guère bécane
qui devait voir le jour d'ici 2018 a
pris du retard en raison de désaccords
entre les élus de la verrière et ceux de
saint quentin en yvelines de vision
d'aménagement un s'opposent celui de la
verrière prévoit la construction de 1800
logements
les détails avec williams à elle c'est
un projet qui est au point mort les 1800
logements du quartier gare bécane de la
verrière
initialement prévue pour 2018 peine à
sortir de terre
la raison selon la municipalité le
blocage du projet par l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
on ne peut pas laisser en tout cas
sortir un projet comme ça qui ne
respecteraient pas ces normes de qualité
ces normes de dix prix village de la
demande d'aidé des verrières watts dont
de toute façon au minimum c'est la
moitié c'est plus qualitatif c'est plus
pavillonnaire c'est pas en augmentant
comme cela la concentration la densité
urbanistique que vous allez améliorer la
qualité selon la mère de la verrière le
projet ne démarre pas car le président
de saint quentin en yvelines aurait pas
encore désigné d'aménageur le projet est
validé il est dans le pays lui 2
de l'agglomération il est dans le
contrat de développement de territoire
enfin on ne comprend pas pourquoi ça
bloque sinon une volonté politique de
monsieur fourgous et de quelques autres
de bloquer parce que à leurs yeux notre
notre projet zac ne correspond pas à ce
que voudrait mais on est chez nous dans
un communiqué l'ancien maire de la
verrière alain ajaj dénonce un diktat
inadmissible de la part de saint quentin
en yvelines
de son côté la mère de la verrière a
envoyé un courrier au préfet pour
demander à l'état de prendre en charge
le projet et de son côté saint quentin
en yvelines affirme qu'elle continue à
travailler avec le conseil départemental
la ville et l'état pour élaborer un
projet prenant en compte les attentes de
chacun
et revenons sur les intempéries après
les intempéries de la fin du mois de mai
début juin une première liste de
communes dans seize départements ont été
reconnues en état de catastrophe
naturelle c'était le 9 juin dernier
l'arrêté interministériel correspondant
à une première série de communes a été
publié au journal officiel de la
république française 57 communes étaient
alors concernés dans les yvelines et un
second arrêté a été publié hier mercredi
15 juin il a déclaré 54 autres nouvelles
communes en état de catastrophe
naturelle dans le département parmi
elles le chesnay magny les hameaux saint
cyr l'école saint rémy les chevreuse ou
encore voisins le bretonneux et parlons
éducation à présent il ya un mois nous
partions la rencontre de deux classes de
l'école régionale de la verrière en
pleine répétition pour enfants en scène
un projet musical porté par
l'association pour la musique à saint
quentin en yvelines
samedi et dimanche ils se produiront
avec neuf autres classes d'école
saint-quentinoise au théâtre national de
saint quentin en yvelines
l'heure est donc aux derniers réglages
un reportage signé nani poker et sephora
namani
et les répétitions aux petits groupes
sont terminés place à la dernière ligne
droite
ce week-end ses écoliers saint
quentinois seront sur la scène du
théâtre national
cette compétition est importante parce
que au début ils ont du mal à comprendre
par exemple pourquoi il ya un champ ils
chantent ils s'arrêtent ils chantent ils
s'arrêtent alors que là une fois que
tout le monde est ensemble ils
comprennent l'enjeu ils comprennent la
construction de ce projet est en fait
ils se rendent vraiment compte qu'ils
ont construit quelque chose ensemble et
ça va leur donner une grande émotion
ensemble sur scène pour chanter l'arche
de noé de benjamin britten sept mois de
travail soutenu par l'éducation
nationale et les communes qui voit
notamment une ouverture culturelle la
deuxième vertu évidemment c'est
c'est une sorte de formation citoyenne
comme on dit c'est à dire tout ce qui
nous permet de faire en sorte que les
enfants soient entre eux deux enfants
deux lieux différents puisque il ya les
enfants de trappes ya les enfants de la
verrière de montigny de plusieurs
communes dans les environs de saint
quentin en yvelines
ça développe tout un tas de choses dont
on n'a pas connaissance aujourd'hui
parce que comme c'est sûr de l'huma
chacun réagit en fonction de ses
sensibilités
il en reste toujours quelque chose qui
ressort à un moment donné il ne reste
plus que quelques répétitions pour ses
244 élèves saint quentinois
ils sont accompagnés par de nombreux
artistes dont les solistes de
lavilledieu avant de se lancer sur la
grande scène
il est temps à présent de passer à notre
entretien nous allons revenir sur un
drame qui s'est déroulé aux états unis à
orlando pardon c'était dimanche 11 juin
omar matane a tué 49 personnes et fait
53 blessés dans une boîte de nuit gay
donc justement à orlando un drame qui a
été revendiqué par die par des chenilles
qui posent des questions sur le climat
of homophobes actuelle aux états unis
mais également en france pour en parler
avec nous notre invité ce soir jérôme
andré président de la chaire prévention
merci d'avoir accepté bonsoir et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation donc je
vois là vous avez été sensibilisés vous
avez entendu parler donc de ce drame ci
s'est passé aux états unis mais est ce
que cela pose des inquiétudes en france
ça pose plein de questions en france
mais pas seulement dans le monde entier
puisque c'est un drame donc c'est un
attentat dont un perpétré par des ch qui
a été effectivement ciblée vers une
communauté gay et pourtant dans les
journaux rares sont les journaux qui ont
parlé de cette tuerie comme étant une
tuerie homophobes et pourtant on est
bien dans le cadre d'une tuerie dans un
attentat meslier donc à l'homophobie
effectivement c'est en ça ou c'est un
peu compliqué aujourd'hui parce qu'on
sent que il y à une homophobie latente à
la fois au monde au niveau dans le monde
mais aussi en france où là on va pas
forcément donc aller plus loin alors il
ya eu des initiatives comme la mairie de
paris qui a effectivement illuminé la
tour eiffel avec les couleurs du drapeau
gay mais on sent que ça reste très
timide et qu'il n'ya pas effectivement
de prise en compte de cet aspect comme
si effectivement les victimes des
attentats on passait sous silence
qu'elle était gay pourquoi selon vous
justement ça a été rendue comme ça dans
les médias on a parlé de cette façon en
maximisant le côté voilà terrorisme high
tech les minimisant le fait que ça a été
vraiment des homosexuels qui ont été
visés ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est horrible on est
effectivement le monde entier est en
prise à des problématiques d'attentats
liés donc à die faut pas oublier aussi
que dahesh cible des communautés
notamment les juifs on l'a vu
notamment les caricaturistes on l'a vu
aussi avec charlie et pour ce qui est
effectivement de la communauté gay
notamment à orlando beaucoup de médias
pas seulement français mais dans le
monde entier ou un peu passé sous
silence qu'il y avait effectivement donc
des gays c'est sûr que c'est plus facile
de dire je suis charlie sur les réseaux
sociaux que je suis gay où je suis
effectivement solidaire d'un attentat
donc en direction des gars et c'est un
petit peu nous ce qui nous heurte parce
que même quand on parle donc de l'uefa
qui aurait pu effectivement faire des
minutes de silence pour la tuerie donc
d' orlando
cinquante trois personnes blessées 49
morts et bien l'uefa dit non il n'y aura
pas deux minutes de silence et ça c'est
un petit peu détestable
parce que pour le coup il n'estime
failli il estime qu' il y à des tueries
régulièrement et que des ch ne peut pas
donc à chaque fois donc provoquer des
vagues des mois comme celle dont on ne
trouve que c'est un peu quand même
regrettable d'avoir ça il ya eu
effectivement le tweet
mais justement les réactions de la
classe politique française il y en aura
assez détestable juste détestable quand
vous avez françois hollande quand même
président des français qui twitte que ce
sont des gens qui ont été tués parce
qu'ils choisissaient leur orientation
sexuelle
beaucoup d'associations se sont portés
effectivement en dix ans mais de quoi
est ce qu'on le parle on ne choisit pas
notre orientation sexuelle je pense
qu'effectivement ce président à un peu
des difficultés avec twitter ou avec la
communication quoi qu'il en soit mais ça
traduit quand même d'un mauvais climat
qui s'installe en france depuis le
mariage pour tous nous on a beaucoup
souffert des des problématiques de
mariage pour tous faut savoir que tous
les gays n'était pas non plus favorable
au mariage pour tous
et là pour le coup on se retrouve en
prise à des actes qui sont donc pas
vraiment homophobes si ce n'est la ctt
d'attentats de dèche
mais on sent qu'il ya un climat un peu
nauséabondes ou bombe a légué on vous a
donné le marié
donc maintenant ça suffit on vous
donnera pas autre chose et là ça
commence à devenir compliqué ça se
traduit en chiffres aussi parce qu'à la
chef prévention on parle de prévention
ist sida
ça se traduit aussi dans les chiffres de
prise de risque notamment sur la
communauté
je vous propose d'écouter eddie aït il
est conseiller régional d'île de france
il s'est battu notamment donc pour le
mariage pour tous il a été défenseur de
cette cause il est des fondeurs
également de la cause homosexuelle c'est
l'ancien maire de carrières sous poissy
il s'est exprimé justement par rapport
au drame d'orlando je vous propose de
l'écouter
je considère que la tuerie dans l'eau
constitue un véritable massacre
homophobes qu'il y as des as
si les homosexuels sont fréquemment
victimes des attaques meurtrières à
travers le monde c'est la première fois
qu'il ya une attaque d'une telle ampleur
49 morts constaté c'est véritablement un
acte terroriste et homophobes et je
crois qu'il faut le il faut dire ce
n'est pas simplement un acte homophobe
c'est un acte terroriste parce qu'il est
revendiquée par beige pour vous ce genre
de réaction ça a manqué dans la classe
politique française mais il y en a juste
pas eu heureusement qu' à eddie aït
notamment pour porter la voix donc comme
il le fait là en disant c'est un
attentat deux as mais c'est aussi un
acte homophobe parce que pour le coup
quasiment peu de gens l'ont dit c'est
quand même c'est quand même compliqué
nous nous on le voit il y à une montée
de l'homophobie
après un net recul on se rend compte qu
effectivement il ya une vraie montée en
puissance de l'homophobie mais de
l'oeuvre mofo dit qu'on pourrait
malheureusement qualifié d'ordinaire
aujourd'hui même nous achève prévention
et pourtant on a beaucoup de salariés
hétérosexuels automatiquement il
travaille avec des gays il travaille
pour des communautés qui sont des hommes
ayant des relations sexuelles avec
d'autres hommes je le rappelle 80%
hétérosexuels père de famille marié mais
qui ont des rapports sexuels avec
d'autres hommes et ils sont caricaturés
comme si effectivement vous travaillez à
chaque fonction donc automatiquement
vous êtes gay et puis on a effectivement
les insultes plus besoin de passer
aujourd'hui par les réseaux sociaux les
réseaux sociaux sont souvent twitter
facebook des exutoires
donc de propos homophobes mais
aujourd'hui on se rend bien compte que
les propos homophobes ou les
comportements homophobes
c'est dans la vie de tous les jours nous
aussi on le subit hf prévention il ya
des gens qui effectivement se permettent
des fois d'avoir des propos qui sont un
peu nauséabondes
on n'en peut plus aujourd'hui on le dit
willy a effectivement une communauté qui
souhaitent communauté homosexuelle en
france qui souhaite aussi s'intégrer et
c'est compliqué d'être intégré quand on
vous le rappelle toutes les deux minutes
et quand effectivement quand il y à des
tueries qu'on ne fasse pas l'effort au
moins de considérer que c'est un acte
homophobe alors je propose d'écouter une
nouvelle fois il y est il a réagi yann
moix lui aussi s'inquiète par rapport
justement à ce climat homophobe est là
tant il n'ya pas d'homophobie ordinaire
il n'y a pas une attention portée parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya près de cinquante
personnes qui ont été tuées il ya une
homophobie qui est aujourd'hui au
quotidien une réalité plus de 80
personnes et affirme avoir fait l'objet
d' insulte ou de moqueries des réseaux
sociaux sont l'objet d'un déchaînement
de propos homophobes donc il ya
aujourd'hui un terreau un contexte qui
fait qu' il faut réaffirmer un certain
nombre de valeurs et l'homophobie comme
le racisme ou l'antisémitisme
compromettrait flamand l'exigence
républicaine d'égalité
quelles sont les solutions les choses
que le gouvernement va prendre en contre
et doit faire pour que justement cette
cette situation on va dire tend à
diminuer sinon à disparaître le
gouvernement je crois que plus personne
n'attend plus grand chose
en tout cas nous à notre niveau ce qu'on
pense c'est qu'il faut réaffirmer les
valeurs notamment communautaires
c'est pour ça que pour la première fois
de son existence
hf prévention a décidé de faire partie
donc de la marche des fiertés de paris à
sa manière c'est à dire avec
effectivement les outils de prévention
qui font hf prévention au quotidien
donc nous serons présents le 2 juillet
place de la bastille puisque le défilé a
lieu de paris montparnasse attristant
14h jusqu'à la place de la bastille
mais pour le coup oui on pense que on
s'est suffisamment tu la communauté lgbt
c'est suffisamment tuer qui va falloir
dorénavant reprendre effectivement le
bâton de pèlerin pour combattre cette
homophobie qui n' homophobie latente et
un moment donné c'est juste détestable
c'est de la prévention c'est du dialogue
vous faites comment quand vous justement
vous vous subissez voilà ces agressions
au quotidien au sein des chefs
prévention alors maintenant c'est très
compliqué pour tout vous dire parce que
effectivement il y à la commune et à
l'homophobie qui est fait par le tout
venant donc effectivement ça va quand on
est sur des marchés ou en train de faire
du dépistage on se prend des réflexions
ou vous dit vous a légué alors que pour
certains ne sont pas gays mais ça va
aussi être des élus de la république qui
vont se permettre d'avoir des propos ça
va être aussi des agents de l'état qui
vont effectivement avoir des propos
alors ça peut être des propos très
homophobe ou des propos qui sont
beaucoup plus ordinaire vous léguez vous
ceci vous cela voilà aujourd'hui nous ce
qu'on pense c'est que effectivement la
communauté lgbt doit se réapproprier
effectivement le terrain doit se
réapproprier les médias doit
effectivement donc ré exister parce
qu'on le sent bien au niveau mondial il
y a eu beaucoup de pays qui sont donc
maintenant qu'ils ont pris le mariage
pour tous et on se rend bien compte que
les valeurs de l'époque de stonewall ne
sont plus défendus réellement parce que
aujourd'hui les gens ne vous considère
plus
merci beaucoup à jérôme andré d'être
venu sur notre plateau d'avoir répondu à
notre question alors je le rappelle il y
aura un hommage qui sera également fait
aux victimes voilà du massacre de
l'attentât d' orlando le 2 juillet à
paris pour la marche des fiertés ou la
gay pride 6 y participerez ce sera à 14
heures début à montparnasse pour finir à
la bastille merci à vous faut nous
allons parler d'un tout autre sujet à
présent culture après deux
représentations sur le bassin de neptune
qui avait conquis 14 me
tu as tort en 2009 blanche neige revient
dans les jardins de l'orangerie du
château de versailles pour quatre dates
et cela jusqu'à vendredi
créé en 2008 par engine 2 prises le caje
le ballet réunis les 24 danseurs
permanents de la compagnie cc fera
namani qui vous en parle
blanche neige revient en majesté dans
les jardins de l'orangerie jusqu'à
vendredi
ce ballet créé par angelin prejlocaj en
2008 connu un succès international
immédiat et obtient en 2009 le globe de
cristal trailer à la dramaturgie très
riche l'oeuvre est la plus populaire des
49 créations de chorégraphes
c'est une nouvelle façon d'aborder la
danse c'est à dire de vraiment raconté
par le corps par les mouvements une
histoire racontée chaque événement parce
que tout y est
j'essayais justement de faire une oeuvre
populaire et de mettre tout mon exigence
décrit dans l'écriture chorégraphique
pour rester au niveau quand même le plus
haut par la danse pure sans descendre à
lhassa et tout en allant quand même vers
quelque chose qui va aussi bien en
chanter une petite fille de 7 ans que
que quelqu'un qu'un homme de 70 ans qui
a découvert sa voie là
cette parenthèse féerique réunis les 24
danseurs de la compagnie d'angelin
preljocaj
créé en 1985 l'adaptation de l'oeuvre
est resté fidèle à la version du conte
des frères grimm de 1812 un compte
encore très contemporain par ces
thématiques autour de l'image et de la
vieillesse
j'ai trouvé que blanche neige était un
compte absolument moderne parce que de
nos jours avec les projets de les
progrès de la science de la médecine la
diététique la cosmétique aussi ça amène
de cette condition cette situation qui
peut faire naître un problème de deux
conflits autour de la séduction
je crois qu'on est dans l'air un peu du
complexe de blanche-neige presse comme
on dit qu'il ya le complexe d'oedipe on
bat notre époque peut-être génère le
complexe de blanche neige par le fait
que les femmes sont plus libres plus
belle et que leur fille finalement
entrent en conflit
de séduction avec elle par rapport à des
prétendants blanche-neige partir à
poursuivre sa tournée en corée du sud
fin juin et pour les amateurs des
chorégraphies d'angelin fraîche l'oqaj
le ballet roméo et juliette sera
représenté au théâtre de chaillot fin
décembre à paris et à présent nous avons
parlé d'une autre forme de culture savez
vous ce qu'est un ou une impro scop
alors c'est un concept qui a été inventé
par andy murray entonnera vos deux
comédiens bien connus à trappes chez
déclic théâtre
le but faire des impros sur périscope ce
réseau social qui donne la possibilité
de fume de filmer et de diffuser tout en
live à travers le monde nous sommes
allés les voir hier soir à trappes pour
leur huitième session je vous propose de
le découvrir en images et skate est en
train de faire un match de basket
la rencontre du joueur de basket lebron
james est le personnage du film the mask
c'est une exclusivité périscope ou
plutôt un pro scop un concept simple
imaginé par andy antoine membres de
déclic théâtre nous donner un mot et ont
fait une impro et l'armée sur la cession
d'ecs et avec périscope le théâtre
d'impro prend un sérieux coup de jeune
pas besoin d'une grosse installation
deux téléphones portables un fond noir
et les suggestions des spectateurs
suffisent le réseau social permet de
filmer et de diffuser en direct avec son
smartphone afin de toucher un grand
nombre de spectateurs à travers le monde
entier à la base on est en train de
bosser sur un projet de pièce de théâtre
et puis on s'est dit ouais faut qu'on
fasse un truc vite fait un rapide et
puis on est tombé sur périscope comme ça
par hasard vraiment par hasard parce
qu'on avait entendu un fait divers tout
bête là dessus c'est pourquoi on ferait
pas un petit show d'un provient ont fait
un essai on a fait un essai un peu entre
guillemets dans le vent et puis on s'est
rendu compte que ça a pris on a fait le
2e 3e 4e 5e 6e et là du coup 1 mais
comme l'a dit antoine talât ont fait là
la 8ème session là on a un peu habitué à
la scène du coup avec le retour des gens
et c'est ça
nous ça nous est vachement à nous à
comment dire à nous à nous placer là
malheureusement
il ya personne qui nous regardent à part
un téléphone et des gens qui sont
derrière en train de nous mettre des
1000 démo de la bonne humeur sur un
média qui n'a pas encore d'utilisation
ou de fonctions vraiment défini ses
sketch improvisé une idée originale qui
a attiré jusqu'à 1650 spectateurs sur
périscope ce qui est hyper bizarre c'est
que on est sur du live et ce moment où
on termine l'impro et qu'on doit laisser
le moment d'applaudir voilà il n'y a pas
de bruyne entend juste l'écart qui font
des ppp eu alors une suggestion ou une
situation drôle a proposé à antoine et
andy les introscope c'est toutes les
semaines sur facebook
le périscope et nous recevons à présent
sur ce plateau notre journaliste sportif
est michael elle me d'euros pour sa
chronique sport du jeu dit bonsoir à
vous amis qu'elle s'emploie merci
bonsoir tous les jeudis sur ce plateau
bien mais c'est un plaisir ça faisait
toujours le bienvenu quel sera le thème
de votre chronique de ce soir est ce que
vous aimez le vtt ne répondait pas je
sais que oui vous êtes une fan de
cyclisme et bien vous allez être servis
dans cette chronique puisque nous avons
parlé du championnat national de vtt qui
sont organisées le samedi 2 et dimanche
3 juillet sur la colline des encours
pour nous parler de cette compétition
nous recevons sur ce plateau thierry
fable président de bce sky et
organisateur de l'événement bonsoir
bonsoir
alors pourquoi avoir décidé d'organiser
cette compétition sur la colline
d'elancourt à elancourt particulière
c'est une belle histoire parce qu'elle
vient de liens de la revancharde qu'on
organise depuis 18 ans et on a fait
venir il ya quelques années
une fédération fsgt qui est venu visiter
le site il ya trois ans ils sont tombés
amoureux de ce si plat puis comme on
avait une renommée de club organisateur
avec saint quentin en yvelines quelque
chose de sérieux dans l'organisation et
la vigne en cours donc nous a proposé de
faire le championnat on a accepté vous
sentez vraiment qu'il y avait une
motivation pour organiser cet événement
de la part la population des politiques
oui énormément ce championnat de russie
beaucoup de soutien oui aussi ce
championnat existe aujourd'hui c'est
parce que saint quentin en yvelines la
ville d'elancourt nous ont soutenus
depuis le premier jour et jusqu'au
dernier ils ont été vraiment nos nos
premiers nos premiers admirateurs entre
partis et puis si j'ai vraiment une
belle association songions n'existerait
pas cela n'existerait pas c'est une
grosse compétition vous avez mis combien
de mois combien de semaines à préparer
cet événement dix-huit mois 18 mans 18
mois et le plus dur ce sont les trois
semaines qu'il reste à faire la dernière
ligne droite c'est comme dans une course
cycliste le plus dur c'est la victoire
pendant le sprint vous allez sprinter
sur les prochaines semaines on sprinte
avec précision alors dites nous en plus
qu'elle sera un peu le tracé du parcours
vous allez partir du bas pour le online
pass et comment alors c'est un circuit
qui est un peu particulier parce que bon
comme sa ville a connu encore six points
cumulant d'île de france
c'est exactement le même tracé que celui
de la revanche a exactement le même
exactement le même c'est un circuit qui
fonctionne bien qui marche bien qu il
reconnu on n'a rien voulu changer départ
du pied de la colline d'elancourt pour
un tout de suite tu n'as qu'une
ascension directe en haut au sommet et
après on reprend un circuit de 7 km 5
pour se retrouver au pied de la colline
pour finir en haut mais quelles sont les
difficultés de ce parcours c'est un
parcours qui associe il sera très
technique
oui adiatou il ya pour les routiers des
grandes lignes droites il ya pour les
techniciens dans les forêts des passages
de rochers il ya pour les descendeurs il
ya pour les grimpeurs les grandes
montées c'est en fin de compte celui qui
sera champion national sera un vététiste
complet
et vous attendez combien de participants
pour ce rendez-vous pour hector
actuellement il ya 600 inscrits c'est un
chiffre que vous attendiez oui parce
qu'on est quand même oui dans une
fédération sait déjà ce sont déjà des
sélections c'est à 23 comités issus de
régions et départements du territoire
national et c'est la première fois qu'il
ya autant de monde sur un championnat
national dont 140 enfants pour les
écoles de vélo et ça c'est une belle
réussite pour nous pour le territoire de
50 nl en cours qui est vraiment des
valeurs sportives pour la jeunesse
dernière question est-ce que c'est
gratuit est ce que tous vont tenir
oui d'accès gratuit il faut venir
nombreux nous encourager valleuse
valoriser ce site qui a peut-être une
histoire importante avec le futur pour
parler du 1024
merci à vous tirer favre merci il vous
reste deux petites semaines pour
l'organisation souhaite bon courage en
tout cas donc les championnats sont
organisés du 2 au 3 juillet sur la
colline d'elancourt j'espère que cette
chronique florennes vous a donné envie
d'aller voir ces compétitions
j'irais bien regarder merci beaucoup une
pièce merci beaucoup
également à thierry fabre d'être venu en
plateau on va se quitter dans ce journal
mais avant juste cette dernière
information le 30 juin débutera sur le
golf national
la 100e édition de l'open de france de
golf le nord-irlandais rory mcilroy tout
numéro trois mondial l'une des stars de
cette édition sera sur place
un concours est organisé pour remporter
et tenter de remporter deux invitations
pour une journée de compétition aux
choix n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
votre écran pour peut-être participer et
gagner d'état s'est rencontré peut-être
cette star c'est la fin de ce journal je
vous souhaite une très bonne soirée de
moins vous retrouvez wilfried errishi
pour votre journal deux fins de semaine
et mickaël hay louis d'euros pour le
sais tu ce week-end au revoir